- Congrats on your baby boy.
So when does he due?
- We got a little boy due in March.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- That's right,
little boy due March.
- A little Aries, good luck.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
But, I never, I never asked this before,
have you named, have
you named your baby yet?
Have you picked a name out for your son?
- We, we, we've narrowed it down,
I think, I think we,
I think we're close.
I'll tell you I, and I'll give you a hint,
it ain't Leslie Odom Jr. Jr.
It ain't Leslie--
- Oh, that's so interesting
because I have this idea
and I don't really think
I've heard it before,
Leslie Odom Juniors Junior.
I had this made and say I had this made
and it's so interesting
because I've thought,
- Oh no.
- You know what?
I think you are a trailblazer, my friend,
and why not be the first
to do juniors junior?
- Leslie Odom Juniors Junior.
- Why not?
Why not?